sí Raúl porque hace unos momentos
terminó la rueda de prensa de títere
seleccionador de la canariña que estuvo
acompañado por su lateral Danilo sobre
lo plenamente deportivo tita dijo que a
la espera de la última sesión de
entrenamiento de la verde amarela que es
esta tarde aquí en doha va a determinar
si alexandro su único lateral Zurdo puro
con el que cuenta finalmente estará
disponible para este encuentro contra
los croatas de no ser así seguramente
podríamos ver de nuevo a Danilo como
lateral izquierdo como ya ocurrió en el
partido contra Corea del Sur Danilo
compañero precisamente de alexandro en
la Juventus que dijo que puede jugar por
la izquierda por el centro del campo en
la derecha por donde prácticamente lo
desee el seleccionador tite que no se
olvidó de Croacia destacó la experiencia
y la gran resiliencia que han tenido los
croatas sobre todo en los últimos años
en los grandes torneos en las fases
eliminatorias Titi además habló de una
de las polémicas que nos dejaron los
octavos de final esa celebraciones de
los goles de los delanteros brasileños
después de esa goleada por 4-1 contra
Corea del Sur dijo tita y quiero que la
gente entienda que en Brasil esa es
nuestra manera de ser nosotros
celebramos con alegría nosotros
celebramos con baile lo vamos a seguir
haciendo y no es una falta de respeto
Juan y y seguimos o con otra noticia en
torno a este mundial porque hay un
reporte sobre la asistencia a estos
partidos que no ha sido la que se
esperaba no que podemos decir sobre esto
Juan
para nada Raúl es un reporte El que tuvo
acceso a la agencia revitres y asegura
que en las dos primeras semanas han
acudido a estos encuentros han llegado
han llegado
765.000 visitantes a Qatar eso estaba
por debajo del objetivo fijado por la
organización por el objetivo estimado de
la Organización de aproximadamente 1,3
millones de personas es un reporte de la
organización filtrado al que del cual
habla Roy tres que habla de esas dos
primeras semanas que son las semanas
pico de este mundial en las que como les
hemos cantado ya Hemos llegado a tener
hasta cuatro partidos al día sobre este
tema Nosotros hemos notado incluso antes
de los comienzos de los partidos incluso
cuando suenan los signos que en los
estadios no hay una gran no hay un lleno
total en los estadios incluso cuando
nosotros los periodistas hemos entrado
de última hora a esos escenarios hemos
notado grandes filas todavía para
comprar las boletas de última hora
conforme van pasando los minutos del
partido si vamos viendo como finalmente
los estadios terminan llenos y
prácticamente que en todos los
encuentros ha habido un lleno total aquí
en Qatar Pero si seguimos notando esa
falta de ambiente este fin de semana sin
ir más lejos en el partido de Inglaterra
en el estadio de albed llegamos al
estadio y las sensaciones prácticamente
desértica es muy difícil todavía notar
un ambiente de fútbol y algo que parece
acompañado de esta cifras que está dando
la agencia roiters al margen de ese tema
una noticia de última hora la real
federación española de fútbol acaba de
anunciar que finalmente Luis Enrique nos
sigue más como el seleccionador de la
roja otro seleccionador que abandona su
cargo después de los resultados de esta
copa mundo Luis Enrique que no superó
los octavos de final aquí que cayó
contra Marruecos en la tanda de penaltis
se habla como Luis de la Fuente
entrenador de la sub-21 como su
reemplazo mientras que en Bélgica hay
reportes de que sería Roberto Martínez
el Antiguo seleccionador de los belgas
quien estaría ocupando también o quien
optaría también al cargo que deja Luis
Enrique